[Music]
Foxcatcher is directed by Bennett Miller
and stars Steve Carell Channing Tatum
and Mark Ruffalo and it's the true story
a very disturbing and creepy true story
of a wrestling team headed by a guy
named John du Pont who's a very rich
wealthy benefactor who lives in this
mansion who invites Channing Tatum who's
a once Olympic gold medalist winner to
practice wrestling and hopefully win
another gold medal now his brothers
played by Mark Ruffalo and the three of
them don't get along very well which
leads to some tragic and very unsettling
results no I love Bennett Miller's last
film Moneyball which also just so
happens to be a true sports related
story and there's a lot of hype behind
Foxcatcher largely because of the
performances particularly Steve Carell
who is unrecognizable as this guy John
DuPont and he gives a performance that's
definitely career-defining at this point
and to say he's creepy in the movie is a
disservice this guy is disturbingly
chillingly disgusting I mean you just
can't even stand to watch him sometimes
not to be overlooked though is Channing
Tatum in this movie who maybe gives the
best performance in the whole movie I
think that a lot of people are looking
at Steve Carell because he's a comedian
and his face is different and it's like
whoa what is he doing but Channing Tatum
in his film gives a performance that is
so restrained and you can read so much
on his face and the moments that he does
have outbursts you can just feel his
pain in the torment of this character
and I think he was brilliant in this
movie but I also want to give a lot of
credit to Mark Ruffalo because he's one
of my favorite actors he has been ever
since I saw him in Michael Mann's
collateral back in 2004 and in this
movie he plays a father who's very
protective of his family but also of his
brother and you can just feel the warmth
in him as a person but you can also feel
his totally legitimate concern when he
sees Carell and Tatum and their
relationship and the strange things that
are happening there he's great in the
movie as well and I honestly think all
three of those performances are worthy
of Oscar nominations I also think the
movie doesn't work without those
performances Foxcatcher is a very
slow-paced movie no I like slow paced
movies this movie is excruciating ly
slow and I'm talking there are moments
where there are entire long three four
five minute scenes and you wonder what
really was the purpose of that scene I
won't spoil
just in case you don't know the true
life story but the thing that John d-pod
eventually does was something that no
one seemed to understand this movie
tries to make a statement as to why he
did what he did and it makes sense but I
do feel like at the core of Foxcatcher
the emotional aspect of it is very
hollow it's an emotionally distant film
that's really hard to read Channing
Tatum's character in the movie is the
one that you feel the most connected to
in a way he's the lead performance of
the movie even though some people are
saying the Steve Carell is the lead
performance in my opinion Channing Tatum
is the heart and soul of this movie you
feel first character you understand in
some ways why he is as tormented as he
is but certain things that eventually
happen in the movie and certain
character motivations just don't make
any sense and a lot of that is because
the real-life story doesn't make any
sense either but I do feel that the
emotional core of Foxcatcher feels very
blank combine that with the slow pace
and the fact that you can't really
understand some of the character
motivations behind this movie certain
aspects of Foxcatcher didn't work for me
I think it's a gorgeously shot movie I
think the performances are completely
out of this world and it's totally worth
seeing for both of those aspects but I
also think that this is a damn good
movie that I never want to see again
have you guys ever had that experience
where you see a film and you're like wow
that was really good
I never want to see that again though
ever because it was just so creepy and
disturbing in all the wrong ways and it
makes you feel icky and dirty like
you're just sitting in a pile of slop
and you never want to experience that
again I'm gonna give Foxcatcher
a b-minus I do think it is a good movie
I just whatever think it's a good movie
that wouldn't be as good unless it had
such anchored and wonderful performances
and the story of Foxcatcher is so
emotionally hollow and difficult to
understand and that's one of the things
that I had a hard time with not so much
the excruciatingly ly slow pace as many
other people have had a problem with if
you've never seen it Bennett Miller film
I'd recommend Capote or Moneyball I
think those are both much better films
than this it is still a good movie and
worth seeing for its performances but
not one that I ever care to see again so
guys I have a question for you what's a
movie that you recognize was really good
but you just you can't even imagine
watching it again thanks as always for
watching guys and if you like this you
can click right here and get stuck mine
eyes
[Music]